christian de boissieu économistes vice
président du cercle des économistes
bonsoir christian de boissieu merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
donc désormais l'état n'assure plus la
prise en charge complète du chômage
partiel
concrètement ça veut dire quoi et
surtout concrètement quelles vont être
les conséquences
la concrètement ça veut dire que les
entreprises montant en régime dans ce
dispositif et est progressivement la
part payée par l'état va se réduire la
part payée par les entreprises
d'augmenter donc on a on a une sortie en
sifflet de ce dispositif alors la sortie
va être plus lente pour les secteurs qui
sont pas des confiné aujourd'hui je
pense hôtel-restaurant eu un certain
nombre de secteurs plus touchés que les
autres les conséquences vous
m'interrogez sur les conséquences à
venir que transportant progressivement
jeu devient progressivement du régime du
chômage partiel en augmentant ce qui est
inévitable parce que le l'état peut pas
continuer à l'appuyer 100% comme ça
pendant des mois on augmenta la part des
entreprises
ça veut dire à mon avis que dans
certains cas le chômage partiel va
laisser la place au chômage tout court
c'est à dire qui il va y avoir moins
embauche par les entreprises et peut y
avoir même dans certains cas des lycées
et licenciements secs donc moi je suis
assez pessimiste sur l'évolution du
chômage en france dans les mois qui
viennent il voit pas comment ça est
extrêmement difficile d'endiguer la
montée de ce chômage l'état on le
rappelle on continue quand même de
prendre en charge 85
c'est quand même beaucoup quelle aurait
été la meilleure solution selon non non
je suis pas en train de vous dire que
c'est pas bon si l'état et l'unedic
mais progressivement le changement
lâchage l'égard des entreprises va
augmenter ce qu'on peut pas ne pas
rester des trimestre comme ça dans le
chômage partiel donc inévitable je pense
que dans le même temps il faut faire un
effort majeur pour essayer de de
contenir on n'empêchera pas la montée du
chômage mais essayer de la contenir un
peu alors ça veut dire ça veut dire
d'abord à mon avis c'est des problèmes
de financement lutter contre les
faillites
qui interviendront dans le tissu des tpe
des toutes petites entreprises et des
pme
bon là il va yards et faillite mais faut
essayer d'en réduire le nord est je vous
donne un exemple concret l'état a promis
de en quelque sorte pour plus de 300
milliards d'euros de crédits bancaires
garantis par l'état justement à 90%
maxime en 90 pour ça mais sur le terrain
et c'est 300 milliards d'euros de
crédits bancaires sont encore là il ya
en proportion il n'y a même pas une pas
150 milliards et d'accorder donc il faut
accélérer l'accès des pme à des
financements qui leur permet de survivre
et en réduisant les faillis de
l'entreprise on va réduire aussi on n'a
pas empêché va réduire la montée du
chômage
et puis il faut réfléchir au problème du
chômage des jeunes la rentrée va arriver
il allait avoir 700 mille jeunes
diplômés pas diplômés qui vont se
présenter qu'est ce qu'on va qu'est ce
qu'on leur propose concrètement qu'est
ce qu'on va leur proposer donc là il
aura besoin aussi sans doute le coup de
pouce de l'état
primal embauche allègements de charges
enfin on connaît déjà le dispositif ça
coûte de l'argent neuf en août où on en
est la dérive des dérives des finances
publiques est telle que ça coûtera de
l'argent en plus mais je répète
enfin dans un océan dépenses publiques
un triste angoisse yeux quand on parle
de chômage partiel on parle
malheureusement aussi parfois de fraudes
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est la cgt 25
% des entreprises ayant bénéficié du
chômage partiel avait en réalité fraude
et faisant site ou même travailler leurs
salariés
des chiffres difficiles à confirmer ma
fille il n'empêche que bruno le maire a
réagi nous savons qu'il ya eu des abus
sur l'utilisation du chômage partiel il
y aura des sanctions
quelle est votre réaction le système
n'est pas parfait mais faut-il faire
écouter le système n'est pas parfait il
ya des effets d'aubaine il ya des
entreprises comment profiter plus que de
mesure et en dehors de la légalité donc
là je pense il sondera il faut des
contrôles et des sanctions
ceci dit je pense qu'on a quand même
globalement eu raison de mettre en place
un régime de chômage partiel qui est
sans doute plus généreux qui existait en
europe au cours des deux mois de
confinement
bon parce qu'on a eu raison parce que si
on n'avait pas fait ça le chômage aurait
aurait monté beaucoup plus vite alors là
à travers ce dispositif qui va être
supprimé en douceur mais en profondeur
on glisse on lis un peu dans le temps la
montée qu'il paraît inévitable du
chômage d'ici la fin de l'année 2020 on
lisse mais ceci dit ça des conséquences
regarder les pannes qui s'est accumulée
qui a été acculé par les 35 ans
rapidement elle va se transformer en
consommation il est conseillé de la
confiance et la confiance ou la défense
ça va dépendre de du marché du travail
et si comme je le crains le chômage
continue continûment augmente
d'ici la fin de l'année 2020 vous allez
voir que les français ils vont continuer
à épargner ils vont au moins consommer
donc c'est le sujet c'est le tueur est
pour moi le coeur de la reprise en
france comme nous doter le coeur de la
reprise et la situation du marché du
travail
ma dernière question aujourd'hui vous
parler des hôtels par exemple tout havre
ouvrir
ils ont d'ailleurs jamais le droit avait
sauvé droit de travailler certains
peut-être préféré rester fermés ou des
restaurants qui ne gagnerait pas assez
d'argent avec les règles qui sont
difficiles à tenir les règles de
restriction
que faire renforcer les contrôles sur ce
type d'entreprise qui préfèrent utiliser
le chômage partiel plutôt que de
travailler à perte ou ou sans gagner
d'argent
abbas il ya des habits oui je suis
d'accord je reviens sur le contrôle et
sanction en même temps le dire avec le
régime des tirages des terrasses qui
s'ouvre ils vont être ouvertes dans les
régions et départements qui resteront
dans la région ile de france
bon ça veut dire que les restaurants
vont faire qu'une partie de leur chiffre
d'affaires
imagine si certains d'entre eux soit un
calcul où on ouvre complètement ce qui
est le cas dans les zones vertes doivent
ouvrir complètement à partir de demain
ou alors on ose partiellement en créant
des terrasses en élargissant des
terrasses et hélas il faut voir ce que
ça rapporte quand qu'un temps et qu'il
faut se remettre au boulot c'est à dire
que tu frappes et quand on écoute
aujourd'hui les restaurateurs il vous
explique quand même que ça fait deux
mois qu'ils ont fermé ben il faut un peu
de temps donc
vont pas ils vont pas se remettre à
fonctionner tous à partir de demain où
quelques jours pour relancer la machine
merci beaucoup question de boissieu
économistes vice président du cercle des
économistes d'avoir été avec nous